ça vous manque motus ou pas thierry
nantes arrête pas là avec le théâtre et
tout ça à moi non mais moi je sais il ya
à peu près un an à peu près jour pour
jour j'étais dans le bureau d'antoine
boilet le secrétaire général de france
télévisions sa division et je buvais un
petit café avec lui
pas au départ et on pense que je viens
pour prendre un café jeu je le lui dis
c'est un jour où il faut avoir un petit
peu plus de courage qu'un autre je lui
ai dit antoine en fait si je t'ai
demandé ce rendez-vous c'était pour te
dire que la saison de motus que je vais
présenter là cette année sera également
la dernière et là il ya eu comme un fait
extendbar et olivier la grande que
l'actuelle nicotiana et puis après j'ai
rencontré tout le monde et notamment
caroline got que je salue parce qu'en
france 2 que je lui embrasse caroline
authier caroline m'a dit abc pas nous
intéresser à ces pannes ou pas ne te
vire pas à peine pas non non non c'est
pas l'arrêt touchant jeudi d'un an je
sais bien que c'est pas vous êtes à
droite a voulu arrêter tulard dit plein
de fois mais où vraiment heureux je peux
je peux le redire sans même jeu d'abord
j'ai toujours dit c'est moi qui prendrai
la main ouais j'ai quand même présenter
et on peut me reprocher de d'avoir
présenté motus mais pas de l'avoir
présenté que 29 ans 29 ans ça fait trois
décennies quand même c'est quand même 29
entasser les moyens de leurs ambitions
que je signe de plus des boules tous les
matins pendant 29 juillet août je
souffre pour juillet-août 90 ouais et 29
ans plus tard voilà je suis dans le
bureau d'antoine et je dis bon 1/3 de là
je suis arrivé au bout de je voulais pas
faire la 30e ali salehi voilà on va
penser souvent la question mais la
récente est que j'avais j'avais plus la
même la même niaque ça sentait pas
l'antenne je te le dis parce que je
viens depuis affaire n'a vraiment allé
personnellement je sentais qu'il fallait
pas que les vannes commencer un petit
peu à se répéter jeu
et puis j'étais arrivé donc ça nous
dérange pas j'étais arrivé au bout de ma
relation avec la chaîne je pensais que
je savais qu'un an après je vais la
pièce il faut que ça change
mais il s'est passé tellement de choses
en plus thierry parce que tu étais jeune
encore témoin là franchement je te vois
tu étais et ai été très bien des
magnifiques je lui dit alors je n'ai
jamais vu aussi en forme tu avais envie
d'arrêter motus où t'as pas envie
d'arrêter la télé ce que tu dis s'il ya
une chaîne black kids propose d'animer
un jeu ou un truc est ce que tu dis non
alors ces zones en moi j'ai toujours dit
j'ai non j'arrête pas la télé moi si on
me propose un programme dans lequel je
puisse être d'accord voilà ce que j'ai
été heureux avec 40° à l'ombre motul et
les mamies et les matins il est très
important
donc voilà donc pas parce que je te
voilà on n'a pas envie taux normal mais
là tu étais encore frais mais c'est vrai
on thierry alors on
non moi car il avait la main un premier
oui oui parce que moi donc je vais avoir
28 ans ça ce n'est pas très intéressant
mais c'est à dire que tous les matins de
ma vie c'est sûr qu'il devient dynamique
mais non mais donc donc c'était je
savais que ceux-ci allumé la télé chaque
matin de ma vie j'avais cette constante
et c'était vous espèce d'alchimie
on ne peut pas décider c'est comme les
tubes de la chanson tu peux pas dire
cette émission elle va casser sa martone
pendant 30 ans c'est des petits miracles
c'est la rencontre avec les
téléspectateurs c'est la rencontre avec
un public et dont je dis souvent mois
des filets jaunes j'en ai reçu sur le
plateau
ces réseaux d'aidé il a jamais été
question que le jeu vous survivent que
quelqu'un d'autre prenne mais j'avais
proposé moi j'avais dit il n'y a pas de
problème ma décision est totalement
adéquat c'est celle que que morale à la
chaîne n'est pas soit ils avaient pensé
à patrick sébastien c'est la bouilloire
direct et bonneville patrick ces parties
où tout y est pour beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
partir comme on sait que patrick
sébastien et d'autres un peu le
maintenant cdd que les personnes arrive
à un certain âge sont remerciés est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas vu par aussi partie
parce que vous sentiez que l'année
prochaine
comme ils ont tendance à sortir un petit
peu toutes les personnes un peu kiki on
est passé 50 ans il y avait ce risque
pour vous je crois - désigne que tu veux
je veux sincèrement senti moins désirés
je croise en cire mois après match et a
eu à la date la surprise de près de 2 de
la direction quant gérait ses sa annonce
vraiment je voudrais thierry y avait
aucun débat soir j'ai bien tout le
travail en plein débat sur livret vie
doit pas faire les mecs qu'on va pas
faire 50 questions donc l escale
intéressant weeds enfin vous avez
maintenant à peu près 10 président de
france télévisions juste une question
est ce que vous leur avez proposé un
jour un format qui vous ressemblent tous
et une émission une émission n'est pas
dans télé câble sat là je fonce à c'est
une bonne question parce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou ça parle d'un sujet voilà j'ai
vu passer président de france
télévisions de les rencontrer à chaque
fois une fois passer tout notre temps là
mais dix fois on pas plus c'est les u18
u19 directeur des programmes et le petit
miracle c'est que j'ai présentées motus
télématin 40 degrés à l'ombre sur les
surprises enfin j'en ai vendu long comme
le bras
mais c'est peut-être le reproche qu'on
peut me faire moi je
je ne sais pas allé jusqu'au septième
étage je n'arrive pas à inverser ces
huitièmes mais voilà vous 8e bosnie j'ai
jamais vu monsieur bolloré sur peugeot
monsieur bolloré c'est pas le père
fouras le directeur général de président
de la chaîne
c'est maxime saada de capitaux vous me
traitez d'abrutis qu'est ce que je fait
quelqu'un me traite de voter puisque
vous faites je le connais bien je
regarde je me calme un petit peu la
carence je suis pas monté assez souvent
tu nous proposer des alors mes jeux de
temps en temps je savais ça devait
arriver mais voilà c'est pas il ya le
savent il ya là de savoir le faire le
savoir faire et faire savoir
tu es arrivée faisait pas sa voiture un
petit à petit peu fragile de ce côté là
ça va mieux mais oui c'est ce que ce que
j'ai demandé souvent c'est à pouvoir
tourner un petit peu plus dans dans
l'efficacité et la réfection de france
droite j'ai jamais bien compris pourquoi
ça ne s'était pas fait alors que j'ai
fait pas mal de main c'est ça qui ont
bien marché en plus voilà donc
exactement
ben maintenant je bats prévoit la pluie
il n' y pas failli